Apple just announced the Mac that I was
most looking forward to and
unfortunately some things are
disappointing While others are
absolutely mind-blowing now Apple flew
through the announcement faster than any
other Mac announcement before so some
things are easy to miss but in this
video I will cover every single
difference between the new 15-inch
MacBook Air and the 13-inch M21 that we
already have the 15 inch air is gonna
feel incredibly thin and light due to
its larger size but the thickness being
11.5 millimeters thin this is the
world's thinnest 15 inch laptop now the
13 inch air is actually 11.3 millimeters
a very slight difference but that will
not be noticeable now as far as weight
the 15 inch air comes in at 3.3 pounds
the 13 is 2.75 so yes it did get heavier
but because is the size is a little bit
larger just like on some other 15 inch
Windows laptops that are lightweight it
feels quite light now just to give you
guys some perspective I have my 15 inch
MacBook Pro right here compared to the
16 inch pro this thing feels really thin
and light but it is actually 15.5
millimeters and over four pounds so the
new 15 inch air is going to be
incredible now the bezels on this thing
are five millimeters which is actually
smaller than the 5.6 of the 13 inch and
because the screen size is wider and
larger they look even smaller and the
notch that is in the center is also less
visible it doesn't look as large takes
up less space and if we compare the 13
inch and the 15 inch air side by side
you actually get a 32.3 percent larger
screen real estate overall which is
quite significant now a lot of people
love the 14-inch MacBook Pro and the 15
inch air will actually have over 16 more
screen real estate which is going to be
incredible while being a lot thinner and
lighter now the screen itself is still
500 nits just like the 13 inch with 1
billion colors with P3 color range it
has the same 1080p webcam and with M2
chips image processing it actually gets
improved and we have the same three mic
array as with the 13 inch now that is
not a bad thing because those
microphones sound great but what has
changed and will be incredible is the
new six speaker system which includes
woofers now with the 13 inch model they
have a quad speaker system with a couple
woofers but people have complained that
it doesn't sound that good uh one guy
actually returned his because he thought
it was defective and the second one
wasn't much better and when we compared
the 13-inch air the M1 model to the M2
the M2 is actually quieter and I prefer
the M1 but with these two additional
speakers we have woofers we have mids
and highs which will make it louder and
sound better now we are ordering
multiples today so make sure you guys
click that subscribe button below for
some Hands-On comparisons but while
those are shipping here's a comparison
of a 14 inch MacBook Pro that has six
speakers compared to the 13 inch air so
you can hear the difference for
yourselves
[Music]
now that is a significant difference and
I'm not sure how much Apple's gonna push
the 15 inch air but we do know it's
going to be a lot better now as far as
battery life I've talked a lot about the
15-inch air having incredible battery
life due to the larger size but
unfortunately this might be the biggest
downside because Apple rated it at 18
hours of battery life and that is
actually exactly the same as the 13-inch
MacBook Air which means that there's a
chance that they put a battery in here
that is barely any larger now of course
the speakers take up some of that extra
room and apple likely wanted to keep the
price down as well as the weight but
what is interesting is that the 13-inch
air in real world use gets about 10 to
12 hours of battery life but with the M2
chips really good for efficiency cores
in low power mode I have got over 20
hours so you can get quite good battery
life especially if you're not pushing it
doing crazy tasks now inside of the 15
inch air we have the same M2 Chip which
some people are going to be disappointed
about because the rumors of the M2 Pro
did not come true but what I will say is
that Apple compared the M2 Chip to the
Intel based MacBook Air and they said
it's 12 times faster and compared to the
15-inch MacBook Pro even though some
specs might be slightly worse in real
world usage you're getting way more
performance way better battery life as
well in a thinner lighter design and
with that it is still fanless which
might be a disappointment because
they're could be room for a small fan
but what I will say is that because the
chassis is larger that will help
dissipate heat and keep it running at
higher performance levels than the 13
inch like we've shown off in previous
videos now the design is identical we
have the same color options the keyboard
looks the same we still have two
Thunderbolt ports along with Max save
charging which is great but none of that
has been improved as far as RAM you
still get eight gigs at the base going
up to 16 and 24. 16 is my recommendation
and as far as SSD it still starts at 256
gig and it can go all the way up to two
terabytes which will cost a lot but I
think 512 is a sweet spot because most
likely the ssds are going to be just as
low on the base model and they get twice
as fast when you upgrade a 512 and that
also improves real world performance so
that would be my suggestion now the
absolute most mind-blowing thing is the
price tag we thought it would cost 14.99
and we were shocked when Apple put 12.99
on the screen coming in at just barely
more expensive than the 13 inch now
Apple did drop the price of the 13 inch
by a hundred bucks and interestingly the
M1 air is still around at the same price
tag so it makes the M2 air a better deal
but for 1300 bucks the 15 inch air is
going to be an incredible deal a great
laptop for pretty much everybody and it
is going to sell absolutely like crazy
so if you want one I would order one
right away or if you want more real
world comparisons make sure you guys
subscribed because we will have those
coming out for the things that spec
sheets don't show off now apple is
positioning this to compete with Windows
laptops they kept giving us specs for
example fifty percent more battery life
than the leading 15-inch Windows laptop
and in real world life that is actually
a bigger difference it is 40 thinner
than the leading 15-inch PC laptop half
a pound lighter and fanless at the same
time so I'm sorry Windows PC fans
um this thing is going to destroy a lot
of competing laptops and we will have
those comparisons coming up as well if
you guys want to see those so personally
for me I think this thing is going to be
killer a couple things are
disappointments but pricing it that low
makes up for those things and it's way
better than them changing a few things
and pricing it at 15 or 1600 like some
people thought this will be the machine
for most people and I'm incredibly
excited to check it out make sure you
guys click that Circle above so you guys
don't miss our real world Hands-On
comparisons which we dive into a ton of
details check out one of those videos
right over there the spin Max and I'll
see you and the next one
foreign